heute meine damen und herren gibt es
auch bei uns am philosophischen
stammtisch nur ein thema fußball
wenn sie jetzt innerlich seufzen liebe
philosophen bleibt doch bitte bei euren
büchern dann kann ich ihnen sagen die
philosophische triple kunst und die
argumentative flanke meiner heutigen
mannschaft haben es in sich
natürlich wie immer mit von der partie
sind katrin noack aus berlin
konrad paul liessmann aus wien und heute
waren gelaufen auch bei uns ist gunter
gebauer ebenfalls aus berlin er ist
professor für philosophie an der freien
universität in berlin und autor dieses
buches das leben in 90 minuten eine
philosophie des fußballs herzlich
willkommen
jaja gebauer normalerweise stellt man
sich den philosophen jasid sahm denkend
am tisch vor viel vernunft wenig
bewegung wenig körper im fußball dagegen
dominiert das vulgäre wie sie selber
sagen viel schweiß körperkontakt kicken
und dreck wünschen sie sich auch bei
wittgenstein und kommt manchmal mehr
dreck nein da ist ja auch ein gewisser
weise etwas dreck im spiel wenn man
richtig lesen kann also man muss die
hinter die seiten gucken also
wittgenstein hat zum beispiel seine
erstmalige skript seiten der späteren
philosophie so verfasst dass er vorne
philosophische überlegungen
aufgeschrieben hat auf der rückseite
bemerkungen wie ich bin ein schwein und
ich kann nicht an gott glauben ich kann
nicht glauben und so weiter und seine
auseinandersetzung mit sich selbst mit
seiner sexualität auch mit seinem
charakter seiner unerträglichkeit usw
notiert also wir haben beides
philosophen sind ja nicht nur diejenigen
die philosophische gedanken
niederschreiben sie sind auch menschen
und als solche stehen sie mit beiden
beinen auf der erde und das interessiert
mich eben versucht sich mit fußball
auseinandersetzt dann setzt er sich
sozusagen mit der anderen seite des
denkens zusammen mit der materiellen
seite des denkens und dafür steht nicht
so erkannt
bekannt ist er auf der seite der
erkenntnistheorie dieser geist
philosophie zu verorten
aber wittgenstein ist in der hinsicht
etwas
der zweite philosophie sehr interessant
wittgenstein war ja ein reiner geist
philosoph im tractatus dann kann der
erste weltkrieg dann wurde er
grundschullehrer in österreich hat 45
jahre unterrichtet dann hatte ein haus
für seine schwester gebaut zwei jahre
architektur auf der baustelle in der
grube hat das ganze haus durch design
bis in die letzten details bis hin zum
schlüsselloch und dann ist er wieder
philosoph geworden und danach ein
anderer philosoph einer der eben auch
schlüssellöcher feilt und einer der sich
im raum bewegt und der körperlich agiert
und das sieht man an seine philosophie
und diese verbindung interessiert mich
herr ließ waren auch sie haben einen
aufsatz über fußball geschrieben in
ihrem buch das universum der dinge da
geht es um das runde leder gehört es
heute fast schon zum guten ton sich als
philosoph auch mit fußball zu
beschäftigen
es gibt in der tat die klage darüber
dass alle zwei jahre das heißt immer
wenn europameisterschaften sind und dann
weltmeisterschaften sind auch
intellektuelle schriftsteller sich zu
fußball äußern vielleicht wirklich schon
zwangs h zwanghaft sich zur fußball
äußern müssen
ganz klar also der dreck ist aus dem
fußball verschwunden also fußball wird
er nicht mehr im internet gespielt
fußball ist nicht mehr die sportart des
proletariats die sie einmal war sondern
fußball ist weltweites riesiges
unternehmen geworden vor allem der
spitzenfußball und soziales in
gesellschaftlicher ist ein politischer
ist ein kulturelles phänomen
und als solcher ein phänomen kann man
sich natürlich auch alles wieder so
herausgefordert fühlen mal darüber
nachzudenken worin die faszination liegt
und es gab aber immer schon immer schon
das übertrieben aber doch schon seit
einigen jahrzehnten versuche fußball
gleichsam ein spiegel der gesellschaft
als spiegel des lebens spiegelt von
ethiker spiegel von regelhaftigkeit zu
interpretieren und philosophisch
fruchtbar zu machen und was macht man
vielleicht heute auch das heißt meine
eingangsfrage mit dem vulgären im
fussball diese these von herrn gebaute
stützen sie gar nicht dass man es nicht
mehr wohl der preis nicht mehr so
schmutzig wie er einmal war außer im
hintergrund also die machenschaften um
den fußball die bestechung
diese form von schmutz ist natürlich
vorhanden
das spiel selber denken hat schon etwas
robust das was wohl wäre so wird er sein
muss primitives ansicht denn nur etwas
mit den füßen zu treten das ist
sozusagen die frühe evolution ehre
existenzform des menschen quasi kaum hat
man den aufrechten gang entdeckt kann
man das tun aber das aus der evolution
wirklich dann hervorgerufen hat nämlich
den gebrauchter ende und gebraucht des
kopfes das wird dir hier dann
gleichermaßen darauf kommen wir gleich
noch lassen sie uns vielleicht kurz die
spieler konstellation klar offenlegen
wir haben hier eine art eine vielleicht
zumindest früher typische situation die
beiden herren sind begeisterte
fußballfans wir beide casino mark und
ich wir gucken uns gerne jetzt in der em
allen spielern mit freunden das hat ja
auch was nettes zusammen zu jugend- oder
zu weinen
aber wir sind sonst jetzt nicht so
fußballbegeistert ist das immer noch
typisch dieser kindergarten fußball fan
ja ich hätte es jetzt erst mal auf eine
andere gemeinsamkeit schon uns zurück
geführt nämlich dass wir beide
schweizerinnen sind und natürlich
gewisse länder mehr oder weniger starke
fußball tradition haben und ich wenn man
von der kindheit aus denkt wir sind doch
mit skifahrer idolen aufgewachsen für
uns waren ganz andere sportarten wichtig
die schweiz hat ja erst in den letzten
jahren so in der art von einem
massenphänomen fußball jetzt auch
wirklich das ist so eine breites
interesse dafür gibt für mich die ich
jetzt seit gut zehn oder zwölf jahren in
deutschland lebe war das eigentlich der
größte kulturelle gap den ich in
deutschland erlebt habe ist dass ich in
land gekommen bin wo fußball relevant
ist und zwar für alle für alle
gesellschaftlichen geschichten für alle
geschlechter für für so seien alle
bildungs- gerade fußball war thema
überall und allseitig und das fand ich
da gibt es natürlich einfach
unterschiedliche traditionen wie wir
relevant fußball für eine gesellschaft
ist und was den gender der betrifft da
glaube ich dass den gibt es natürlich
mein fußball ist ja fast die einzige
sportart wo ist die sportart gibt und
dann den frauenfußball es gibt ja nicht
tennis und frauen tennis oder schwimmen
und frauen schwimmen
aber es gibt im fußball und
frauenfußball wieso das gestoppt es gibt
doch
tennis herren und tennis für lahm hat
mich frauentennis und meinem berater
ausgegeben werden schlicht und schön ist
wenn ich jetzt mal sagen darf dass es
gibt diese ganz alte beobachtung der
feministischen philosophie dass es eben
so zu sein dass allgemein also schon bei
boa findet man dass das menschlich
allgemeine gelogen dass man das ist eben
männlich und weiblich ist das
partikulare davon abgeleitete andere die
kann man den fußball natürlich sehr
schön sehen es gibt in den fußball und
den frauenfußball
tatsächlich fand ja die erste
frauenfußball weltmeisterschaft zu 25
jahren statt herr gebauer warum werden
die frauen spiel eigentlich immer noch
zu schlechteren zeiten gesendet das
interesse ist gering
daran muss man sagen die frauen spielen
einen sehr guten fußball und einen etwas
anderen fußball als die männer der auch
von vielen männern durchaus geschätzt
wird
achja ich gucke mir das durchaus an aber
ich bin ich mit derselben begeisterung
für männerfußball
ich glaube das stimmt natürlich was sie
gerade gesagt haben von mann und frau
mag frauenfußball ist insofern anders
als der männerfußball dominierend ist
also man hat das dominierende modell den
männlichen fußball das zu treten das
ballern das schießen den kraftvollen
umgang mit dem ball den sehr freien
gebrauchter beine und füße
das finden wir und auch in der
weiblichen sozialisation lange nicht so
ausgeprägt wie in der männlichen also da
gibt es ja ganz unterschiedliche wege
ich will damit nicht sagen dass frauen
nicht fußball spielen können gottes
willen aber es ist für eine junge
sozialisation für die für das aufwachsen
eines jungen mannes irgendwie viel
normaler dass man mit dem fuß zuschlägt
dass man ballert dass man tritt kommen
hier so norm vorstellungen dass die
person vermutlich einem handstreich oben
ich glaube es ist auch eine realistische
beobachtung es gibt ja viele auch der
sportsoziologe oder philosophie diese
beobachtung dass natürlich mädchen nicht
zu sportiver aktivität erzogen werden
also diese ganz klassische aufsatz ring
gleich egal also man sieht sozusagen
kleine mädchen noch sehr sportiv und
natürlich mit ihrem körper umgehen aber
dann die weibliche sozialisation eben zu
dieser verkümmerung dass man dann eben
nur noch so schmeißt also dass man eben
gar nicht mehr so seien seine eigene
kräftig kite ausübt und da mal was dran
sein
ich meine ich finde mein fußball kommt
eben noch etwas spezifisches hin zu
fußball dass er fast die einzige sport
hat die wirklich verboten wurde für
frauen also es gibt ja so ab
20 jahren gibt es in verschiedenen
nationalen verbänden den verbot des
frauenfußballs das erst dann wird wieder
so ein 50er 60er 70er aufgehoben wird
also es gibt beim fußball nicht starten
und die argumente dafür waren immer dass
es so weibliche sittlichkeit anstand und
anmut verletze genau dieses spiel mit
den bayern die sehr robuste spiel und
ich glaube natürlich haben wir sind wir
von diesen verboten sehr weit entfernt
aber wir haben natürlich eine ästhetik
geben diese ästhetik der robustheit der
ästhetik des zu treten
die nach wie vor mit unseren sehr
gängigen vorstellungen von geschlecht
und von weiblichkeit nicht unbedingt
kompatibel ist und umgekehrt haben wir
den fußball auch als sehr primären
wendigkeit markt ist das noch sagen ich
weiß dass ich schon der ist ja ich kann
mir das nur räuspern weil ich gestehen
muss dass mich diese debatte überhaupt
nicht interessiert überhaupt nicht ich
finde auch prinzipiell dass nicht immer
alle alles machen müssen
und die findet kein problem daran dass
männer fußball spielen und frauen was
anderes machen warum oder auch fußball
mögen
egal auch nicht interessiert
frauenfußball nicht muss ich gestehen
theoretisch würde ich sagen vielleicht
wird aus dem grund der mit dieser vorhin
angesprochenen robustheit und
primitivität zu tun hat es hat was egal
ob jetzt kulturell bedingt sozial
bedingt genetisch bedingt
evolutionsbiologisch bedingt kann mit
viele theorien darüber formulieren aber
es hat was glaube ich der fußball hat
was mit der aktions weise von
menschlichen körpern von männlichen
horden und männlichen gruppen von jagd
gruppen zu tun
das spielfeld so wie es hier sehen klare
grenze 2 gegen das ist eine
kriegssituation man kann das alles
natürlich auch für frauen öffnen aber
ich sehe jetzt wirklich keinen
zwingenden grund war ein missverständnis
dass es darum also in der analyse geht
erich thumm nur um diese öffnung ist das
wäre vielleicht eine politische
wünschenswerten der analyse ist es doch
relevant auch diese männliche codierung
des fußball natürlich hier gemacht auch
schon aus medien und wirtschaft von der
mitte geben finde ich dann wiederum auch
nicht uninteressant man wenn man sich
die intellektuelle beschäftigung mit
fußball anschaut weil es natürlich auch
der sonst für intellektuelle vielleicht
auch nicht um relevante sich eben mit
diesen männlichkeitswahn genau darum
geht es um eine diskussion zum fußball
es gibt noch viele dinge die wir die wir
brechen wollen machen die ihr kurz einen
schnitt und überlegen uns mal was ist
eigentlich das erste wasser in den sinn
kommt wenn man sich aus philosophischer
sicht mit fußball auseinandersetzen ich
glaube die meisten kommen irgendwann
wenn sie diskutieren auf das legendäre
fußballspiel der griechischen
philosophen und der deutschen
philosophen gegeneinander
die sketch der britischen komiker gruppe
monty python von 1972 die haben die
griechischen philosophen gegen die
deutschen philosophen antreten lassen
zuerst wissen die herren eigentlich
überhaupt nicht was sie mit dem ball
anfangen sollen
bis auch im e dass die zündende idee hat
kicken muss man und er schreit heureka
schauen uns diese szene an archimedes
lied sokratis der spiel zurück
juni das zu heraklit geht vorbei an marx
gefahr vom deutschen tor archimedes
völlig 3 kommt an den ball flankt zu
sokrates sokrates kopfball ins tor 1 0
durch so kam es in der letzten sekunde
hertz hinzu kommt es durch kopfball das
entscheidende 1 0 für die griechen und
die deutschen diskutieren hege
argumentiert otto logisch dass die
wirklichkeit a priori nur einnehmen
umstadt naturalistische tätigen ist kann
protestiert mit dass des kategorischen
imperativ das tor existiere nur in der
imagination und magst behauptet es war
abseits konfuzius antwortet mit dem
schlusspfiff das spiel ist zu ende die
deutsche mannschaft ist geschlagen durch
ein bildschöne store ist eigentlich
philosophisch klang was die griechen
hier gewinnen müssen
ich glaube ja titel die deutschen
idealisten schon gegen mag es nicht
unbedingt
ich würde sagen mag es hat ja auch ein
tor verdient gehabt in diesem spiel da
vielleicht auch noch nietzsche wenn man
ihnen aufgestellt hätte aber da sagst
offenbar auf der reservebank also das
aus dessen tor schießt finde ich
befremdlich so kalt ist es nicht
unbedingt der mann der großen aktion das
ist der mann des jährigen die erkenntnis
seiner selbst und die sie das streben
nach weisheit und wahrheit in den
vordergrund gestellt hat den hätte ich
mir lieber so wie er auch geschildert
wird in der antike vorgestellt nämlich
abseits stehend in sich vergröbert
denken darüber nach welche rolle er
jetzt in den ganzen spiel spielen könnte
so werde er bisher dargestellt aber es
ist unglaublich lustig und witzig dass
man philosophen fußball spielen lässt
also ich hätte zum beispiel gerne als
mittelstürmer für meine truppe
wittgenstein aufgestellt und nietzsche
als flügelstürmer dann wäre noch tore
gefallen sagen sie vielleicht doch
kurzen das wäre ja wittgenstein als
jemand der eine eine neue art des
philosophierens eingeführt hat die sehr
stark auf elemente des spiels setzt das
war auch für mich da ansatzpunkt für
meine beschäftigung mit dem
fußballspielen die philosophische
beschäftigung nämlich das sprachspiel
und diese parallelisierung von dem
funktionär der sprache und in
funktionieren eines spiels mit 22
personen also zwei mannschaften zwei
kollektiven wenn man so will zu einer
einzigen sprachgemeinschaft fusioniert
hier auf dem feld in einem super
sprachspiel sozusagen miteinander
beschäftigt ist bedeutung zu bilden das
ist nicht der punkt ich komme also von
der theorie der bedeutung her und denke
das fußballspiel ist ein wunderbares
beispiel an dem man sehen kann wie
bedeutung gebildet werden herr ließ man
sie sind ja jemand der den fußball auch
wirklich einbettet in ihrem text in das
größere in den größeren zusammenhang des
spielens und sie streichen aber auch
heraus dass der mensch eben der homo
ludens ist der mensch hat immer schon
gespielt warum spielt denn der mensch
oder was ist auch speziell am mensch aus
spielendes wesen also ich glaube das
wird es interessant ich bin nicht der
teil nicht ihre these dass sozusagen
jedes spiel ausgespielt wird bedeutung
generiert als ich im fussball generiert
überhaupt keine bedeutung haben uns ja
gleich anderen jahren aber es ist
natürlich eine variante variante eines
spiels das aus unterschiedlichen gründen
reflexion bedürftig ist einerseits weil
die frage warum spielt der mensch
überhaupt das ist ausdruck man kann
spieler zitieren oder andere tatsächlich
ein ausdruck vielleicht neben kunst aus
seiner freiheit denn spiel heißt immer
es ist nicht ernst es geht um nichts
ernstes es geht darum einen
abgesicherten bereich zu haben indem
ganz andere gesetze gelten als sonst im
leben
es geht darum ein regelsystem zu haben
das sonst so nirgendwo gilt dass ihm
genau das spiel vom leben trennt es geht
darum sich diesen regeln einerseits in
freiheit zu unterwerfen und andererseits
an diese regeln zu erfüllen wenn möglich
auch zu gehen wie auch immer aber alles
geschützt durch diesen satz es ist ja
nur ein spiel und dieser satz ist was
unglaublich befreiendes oder hat mich
was unglaublich feiern das und das
zweite ist natürlich es gibt
unterschiedliche varianten von spielen
sind noch immer wieder reflektiert
worden häussinger kaja und andere und
das fußballspiel ist natürlich für mich
gereizt auf zwei aspekte erst ein
klassisches wettkampf spielen ja es ist
kein glücksspiel
es ist kein spiel große um ästhetische
generationen hervorbringung entgehen was
wir auch kennen es ist kein ethisches
spiel die das theaterspiel der armen
hier nichts nach außen gesagt bisher
nachahmung von spielerischer nachahmung
von kampfsituationen sollen es ist ein
wettkampf ist ein wettkampf und es muss
am ende wenn es irgendwie geht einen
sieger geben und jemand der eine
niederlage zu verdauen hat und das
zweite ist sagte dass nur kurz sagen das
ist mannschaft spielt das ist kein spiel
kein wettkampf einzeln einander
gegenüberstehen wie zum beispiel an den
ist oder beim tennis oder bei anderen
wettkämpfen es ist kein spiel wo der
sieger ermittelt wird in dem
nacheinander jeder das gleiche tut hier
seit er beim skilaufen spiel wirklich
mannschaften gruppen aufeinander stoßen
das ist sozusagen die cdu ließ man
spiele sind unernst das ist etwas was
wir nicht unbedingt vorher ich habe
gesagt nicht durch viele unernst dass
man zu sagen ich spiele so sein sind
getränkt durch ihr system von ernst des
lebens ich kann schreibt oder eben nicht
so gesagt haben gesagt naja ihr wille
sein kann als sehr ernst betreibers ist
es ist sie sind trotzdem nur ein spiegel
ja gut so so finde ich das schon richtig
also sieht spiele können enorm ernst
sein fußball ist natürlich ein beispiel
es gibt in aus der ethnologie etliche
beobachtung viele beobachtung dass
spiele ganz eng mit dem religiösen
verbunden sind und spieler auch bis auf
leben und tod gehen können sie haben
natürlich recht wenn sie sagen ist zum
ernst des lebens getrennt aber nicht
dadurch dass es uns ernst ist wenn wir
diese spielfeld wir nehmen diese fläche
mit der auslinie kann man sagen was hier
passiert und das wort das ist was
anderes
er ist geht manchmal über die grenzen
hinaus das wissen wir auch aber es ist
ganz wichtig dass das was hier im
spiegel jetzt passiert erst mal regeln
konstituieren muss die regeln stehen
zwar im regelbuch aber wenn sie nicht
befolgt werden dann gelten sie nicht das
ist im leben ja nicht so das leben ist
der verstärkte regel freien raum und
stück weit auch gekennzeichnet ist der
regel im spiel klar real so klar sind
die regeln im fußball eben nicht es gibt
viele spieler die haben viel viel
klarere regeln hier gibt es aber ein
schiedsrichter der festlegt ob etwas
abseits war hat etwas ein tor war oder
nicht und wir wissen aus vielen vielen
diskussionen dass das relativ
diskussionsfähig ist das ganze das ist
gar nicht so selbstverständlich ist und
die regeln im spiel überhaupt erst
dadurch entstehen dass die spieler sich
entweder daran halten oder von
schiedsrichter sanktioniert werden also
eine regel entsteht nicht einfach so und
das ist auch wieder wittenstein für
philosophie regel folgen kommt dadurch
zustande dass die leute sich nach regeln
verhalten wenn sie das nicht tun gelten
sie nicht als zum beispiel darf man
gegenspieler nicht verletzen was tun
aber fußballer wenn sie hochspringen sie
hauen im gegenspieler dem ellbogen ins
gesicht oder inhalts so dass sie
verletzt auf dem boden liegen bleiben
und kommentator im fernsehen sagt das
hat er nicht gewollt das war einfach nur
hoch springen usw also entstehen
plötzlich neue regeln oder die
sogenannte notbremse ist es eigentlich
verboten
ein spieler zu fall zu bringen aber wenn
es geboten ist wenn es interessant ist
gegenspieler eine gute chance hat dann
sehr selbst man ihn um dann kriegt er
einfach nur in den meisten fällen ein
freistoß der gegenspieler aber seine
chance ist dahin
aber eigentlich sagen so einfach hat
neue regeln sondern es ist einfach der
regel verletzt und die frage ist wie
stark muss die sanktions seien aber die
einstellung nicht ins detail meine
herren weiter kommen sonst nichts zu den
einzelnen themen
was ist genau noch einmal jetzt mit
dieser idee gemeint dass das spiel ein
primitives spiel ist das haben sie ja am
anfang eingeführt und sie herr gebauer
betonen ja dass das ist spiel der
fußball ein stück weit die evolution des
menschen rückgängig gemacht erklären sie
das nochmal damit sollen das gemeint
also durch die aufrechnung des menschen
dann braucht für seine evolution sind
die hände frei gestellt von der
fortbewegung und damit frei für eine
freie gestaltung und nun gibt es sehr
gute theorie den letzten jahrzehnten
noch ausgezeichnet bestätigt sind das
aus dem freien gebrauch der hände so
etwas wie kreative tätigkeit entsteht
daraus
kann so etwas entstehen wie formung von
wirklichkeit indem man zb ton formen
sind die man gesten macht aus der
begriff begreift sind des reuttener
gesten dann als vorstufe dass sprache
verwendet so dass man sagen kann aus dem
hand gebrauch entstehen alle hören
fähigkeiten der zivilisation die über
symboliken zeichen formung mimetischen
formung künstlerische tätigkeit und so
weiter geht das alles ist im fußball
verboten weil die hand verbinden
nur der schiedsrichter darf den ball
verzeihung der darf auch den beinamen
aber der torwart auf den ball greifen
aber nur in dem raum der ihm zugewiesen
ist außerhalb kriegt eine rote karte und
musste spieler alles von neuem aufbauen
was er an körperlichkeit als mensch in
unserer zivilisation mitbekommen hat er
muss also sein körper um kodieren da
muss alles das was sonst die hände frei
machen können telefon werfen genau
zielen usw muss er jetzt mit den füßen
machen das gibt es in keiner anderen
sportlern das gibt es in keiner anderen
sportler in den fall einer berühmten
bekannten sportlers gibt es in kemer
einer höfischen am höfischen ballspiel
am kaiserhof vom kyoto um 11 112 113 107
sind wirklich immer die hände betätigt
man entweder sind es die das war alles
auch bald stoppen zum beispiel das ist
auch philosophisch gesehen ein
interessantes moment oder dass man
sozusagen sagt unser eigentliches
denkwerkzeuge der philosophie ist er der
kopf die vernunft und jetzt plötzlich
beginnt man sich dafür zu interessieren
was eigentlich den füßen passiert in
gewisser weise könnte man auch sagen das
ist sozusagen fast schon die umkehr
figur des philosophierenden denkens und
interessant in diesem zusammenhang auch
immer dass es unglaublich viele leute
unglaublich lustig finden diese sprüche
zusammen
der fußballer dieses jahr zum teil jetzt
nicht weil ich unglaubliche
intellektuelle gebildet ausdrücken
es gibt ganze website sich die sprüche
mehr zusammen tragen vielleicht legendär
der spruch von valentin stocker
prozentual stehen die chancen 50 zu 70
oder andreas möller ich hatte vom
feeling her ein gutes gefühl
es gibt ganze serien von euch
entsprechend von newark diese lust daran
sich sozusagen über den kopf hinweg zu
setzen kann sie als philosophen damit
etwas anfangen
ja sie natürlich ist es für philosophen
immer sehr interessant was mit der
leiblichkeit passiert und in dem sinne
verstehe ich auch diese faszination für
den fußball als spieler so gerade in dem
sinne wie herr gebauer ist beschreibt
weil man sozusagen nicht nur über den
leib nachdenkt was für die philosophie
sowie so auch immer eine interessante
sache ist sondern auch noch über einen
sehr spezifisch sozusagen gerichtet und
disziplinierten leib und damit sozusagen
über über einen bereichen wo
leiblichkeit noch mal ganz anders
problematisch oder interessant wird und
natürlich glaube ich es ist auch einfach
so eine art von philosophischer
sehnsucht in dieser sportlichkeit und
leiblichkeit mehr zu hause zu sein also
wir uns über diese sprüche der fußballer
lustig machen macht man sich ja auch
über uns philosophen lustig weil wir
eben nichts können außer mit dem kopf
denken und dann ist es natürlich ich
glaube dass diese ganze auch
intellektuelle faszination für den
fußball auch so ein bisschen diese lücke
versucht zu schließen zwischen den
leuten die eben brennen können den
leuten die denken können die denker
würden gerne rennen und kicken können
und die kicker würden vielleicht auch so
die großen profi fußballer wenige von
ihnen stammen aus bildungsnahen
haushalten
das ist oft eben sind oft auch personen
mit migrationshintergrund die jetzt
nicht in erster linie eine riesige
schulkarriere gemacht haben das ist ja
alles neue jetzt die guten spieler der
gegenwart kommen aufs sportgymnasium
sie haben also abitur gemacht also meine
these stimmt nicht nein gestimmt absolut
nicht das moderne spielsystem ist auch
für migrantenkinder sind berühmte fall
jetzt im augenblick boateng in der
bundesrepublik deutschland gerade
diskutiert wird
boateng ist neuerdings kapitän der
deutschen nationalmannschaft im letzten
spiel gewesen und er ist ein
ausgesprochen intelligenter mann sie
müssen mal interviews mit ihm lesen
er hat natürlich seine schule gemacht
hat letztlich abitur gemacht mittlere
reife aber hat durchaus ein gewisses
intellektuelles potenzial aber es geht
jetzt nicht darum ein fußballer
integrieren zuletzt würde mich schon
interessieren weil es wird ja viel und
mir ist es ja einigermaßen
verschlossener bereich das wird ja viel
leben über dieses über dieses
intelligenz von spielsystemen geredet
und ich meine was ihre these würde ja
darauf hinweisen das ist natürlich
sozusagen eine eine evolutionäre
sozusagen primitiven ist mit den füßen
aber zugleich gegen hochintellektuellen
das baltische spiels ist ein reiner
bayern denken mit den füßen was dann
entsteht und das ist das was mich daran
interessiert ich will mal sagen warum
nicht das so interessiert von
wittgenstein heer von seiner
sprachphilosophie bei wittgenstein gibt
es eine enge verbindung zwischen
bewegung und bedeutung also die tatsache
dass wir bestimmte bedeutung bilden
nehmen wir mal an das wort begreifen das
ist ja nur eines der wichtigsten worte
der philosophischen sprache hängt sie
eng zusammen mit der tätigkeit der hände
des greifen
man kann zum beispiel feststellen ich
arbeite mit einem euro linguisten
zusammen friedemann pulvermüller daraus
cambridge zu uns gekommen ist und einer
der hervorragendsten fachleute auf
diesem gebiet ist er kann zum beispiel
zeigen dass bei allen worten mit hand
gebraucht also begreifen fassen erfassen
dass also auch beim abstrakten
wortgebrauch die motorische das
motorische zentrum des hand gebraucht
aktiviert wird und wir machen jetzt eine
untersuchung mit den füßen
das heißt wenn im profi fußball darunter
auch ein paar ehemalige nationalspieler
die sich bereit erklärt haben und
schauen ob sie ein vertieftes
semantisches verständnis haben für alle
wörter die mit fuß zusammenstoßen
ballack dann sozusagen das in ihren das
zentrum aktiviert wird
abstrakter und dann wird hinterher
geprüft inwieweit wieder so manches
verständnis vertieft ist das kann man
machen das sind sehr langwierige tests
ist man da ganz dankbar beim bekannter
sportler gefunden hat wo man stellt dann
fest man kann möglicherweise wir sind
natürlich noch nicht am ende
aber das wäre jetzt in der logik auch
meiner eigenen arbeit dass man eine
gewisse intelligenz diesem teil auch
eine semantische intelligenz
interessanterweise über das spiel mit
den füßen gewinnen kann nämlich wenn man
den ball von hier
nehmen wir mal an von hier jetzt rüber
spielt hier müssen sich jetzt noch ein
haufen spieler dazwischen vorstellen die
hier alle rumstehen und decken
wenn hier hat das macht zum beispiel
denkt den ball von hier so weit drüber
spielt jetzt den mund nehme man das
selbe mannschaft dem genau vor die füße
dann muss dieser spieler alles irgendwie
kassiert haben
das ganze die ganze biografie die vor
ihm ist auch das zusammenspiel und das
was daraus wird
da muss also auch antizipieren können
die einlauf mir die anderen dahin und
weiter muss antizipieren kann und dem an
ein spieler den ball
hinschickt und der fängt ihn sozusagen
mit dem fuß mit dem spann ganz leicht
auf und klicken sich vor und schießt in
der natur also das ist denke ich eine
form der spielintelligenz und bedeutungs
bildung nämlich dass man eine neue
situation schafft man mit einem schlag
erkennt sowie über fußball
also ich finds ich bin skeptisch ist
paradox auf der einen seite dem fußball
sozusagen als eine und text um rücknahme
der evolution zu sehen
das heißt also reduzierung der tätigkeit
der hände das heißt also reduzierung auf
der fähigkeit mit den händen zu
begreifen zu erfassen und dergleichen
mehr alles mit dem fuß zu machen gleich
seine form vom primitivität aber man
kann heute natürlich niemanden mehr
vorwerfen oder oder auch nur beschreiben
zugestehen dass etwas positives macht
ist muss man jeder intelligent sein als
erster fußballer mit seinen beinen
offensichtlich auch intelligent
natürlich gibt so etwas wäre
spielerischer motorische strategische
intelligenz natürlich muss hier
kommuniziert dann fällt das müssen als
menschen und sozusagen miteinander das
spiel aufziehen
ich würde das aber bedeuten mäßig
einfach nicht über determinieren wenn es
so wäre dass diese form von bewegung mit
den beinen mit den füßen tatsächlich
auch semantisch intellektuellen gehalt
haben könnte dann hätte sich das in der
sprache schon längst durchgesetzt und
bedeuten würde
der computer zum beispiel sowie bei
begreifen
dieses wort hatte nicht nur die
bedeutung etwas angreifen sondern etwas
auch geistig erfassen
dann würde etwa bei ja wie sie sagen
fall an wir auch seine geistig bedeutung
haben ich höre argumenten von dem hier
gehen wir ein schritt weiter ein ein
wichtiges thema wenn wir über fußball
diskutieren und auch in der philosophie
über fußball diskutieren ist immer auch
die frage was tun wir da eigentlich wenn
wir eine mannschaft bejubeln und warum
sind wir eigentlich für unsere
mannschaft warum freuen wir uns
beispielsweise wenn unsere
nationalmannschaft sieht audimax sie
beschäftigen sich schwerpunktmäßig mit
massen emotionen mit der frage überhaupt
auch geteilter emotionen
was passiert da eigentlich genau also
ich finde vielleicht müssen wir da noch
mal einer show zurück geht nämlich wir
reden ja immer auf zwei ebenen über
fußball wir reden jetzt vertieft über
dieses spiel
wer spielt dieses spiel natürlich ticken
viele von uns in der freizeit und so
weiter und da sind in einer kleinen
mannschaft aber wenn wir über fußball
reden in unserer gesellschaft müssen wir
ja immer auch über darüber reden nicht
über diejenigen die fußball spielen
sollen über diejenigen die fußball sind
passiv konsumieren also das
massenphänomen fußball ist ja eben das
zuschauern weil im fußball und ist schon
noch ein unterschied da geht es nicht um
die intelligenz der füße da geht es ja
irgendwas ganz anderes und natürlich
glaube ich dass da gibt es so viele
verschiedene richtungen die das
interessant ist und eine richtung wo es
ist für die emotionsforschung eben ein
ganz interessantes feldes der fußball
ist dass das so ein laboratorium muss
wenn man beobachten kann wie eigentlich
emotionale ansteckung funktioniert oder
die massen emotionen funktioniert weil
die psychologie und auch die
philosophische psychologie und emotions
theorie geht eigentlich schon
traditionell immer sehr davon aus dass
die emotion das gefühl vom individuum
ausgeht das ist ja so ein tiefes inneres
ding das ist in meiner seele und so
weiter das hat so zu sein dass auch
regen teil meiner persönlichkeit
struktur und dagegen gibt es natürlich
aber immer auch die simple tatsache dass
der mensch ein soziales wesen ist und
emotionen offensichtlich sehr viel
stärker in gemeinschaften entstehen als
als oft in der psychologie angenommen
wird und fußball ist das ist wunderbar
zuzuschauen weil ein fußballspiel das
ist vielleicht kann man das auch ein
bisschen wie aristoteles qatars ist also
wie das theater bei aus sodass man geht
dahin man leidet mit man freut sich mit
aber man tut es eben immer in der gruppe
und da bin ich natürlich ein gutes
beispiel weil ich eben so von haus aus
jetzt keine erhöhte faszination für den
fußball habe aber natürlich wenn dann
mal em ist und wenn das alle schauen
dann komme ich nicht umhin mich von
diesem fußball fieber in irgendeiner
weise anstecken zu lassen
es gibt ja sehr gute untersuchungen zum
beispiel von dem phänomen
und hermann schmid über so etwas wie man
in stimmung
sozusagen gerät also man kommt ganz
normal man hat einen guten tag und es
hat sich in einer gruppe die ein gefühl
hat und sofort oder fast automatisch x
angesteckt er hat das beispiel
pylonenfehler also ein krieg aber ist es
passiert ist genau so etwas dann kommt
ihnen diese gruppe und fiebert mit
das heißt die emotion kommt nicht von
mir sondern die wird von außen an mich
herangetragen aber von mir ähnlich
empfunden und das ist die philosophie
sagt er weil ich genau sehen hier immer
für unsere mannschaft warum ist das so
dass man eigentlich ja sehen kann dass
viele leute sich jetzt nicht so stark
mit ihrem land identifizieren aber kaum
geht es um fußball ging das sofort ich
glaube dass es sehr stark auch ein
phänomen das man mit religiösen phänomen
vergleichen kann das ist jetzt
vielleicht etwas hoch gegriffen auf den
ersten blick gehen was macht es so
erscheinen aber im detail sich anschaut
der kern einer großen emotionen im
stadion wie sie sagen von der dann diese
emotionale ansteckung ausgeht sind die
fan gruppen das sind diejenigen die die
großen motoren der hat der stimmung sind
da sind dann im westfalenstadion in
dortmund 40.000 leute die auf der
südtribüne wie ein mann schreien und
anfeuern usw
daraus ist natürlich sehr mächtig und
daraus entsteht so etwas wie eine
gemeinde die ihre kraft ihren spielern
zur verfügung stellt und die spieler
empfinden das auch so dass ein wie ein
religiöses jedenfalls sah man türkheims
beschreibung primitiver religionen
annimmt dies von 1900 ist er alt aber
die ist neuerdings wieder aufgenommen
worden weil es sich sehr gut zeigt dass
bei religiösen phänomen so etwas
zutrifft und zwar solche religiösen
phänomene die jetzt nicht gerade
christliche religion oder eine
offenbarungsreligionen es natürlich
nicht sein
religion die entstehen aus ritualen
rituale sind dann körperliche praktiken
die zu bestimmten zeiten an bestimmten
orten von ganz vielen menschen in
gleicher weise ausgeführt werden singen
tanzen schlacke springen vielleicht noch
trinken dazu wenn sich die religiöse
gesänge anschaut
also ich sage schon religiöse geschenke
gesänge bei die tatsächlich diesen
geheilt haben aus englischen stadien you
never walk alone oder bei wird und so
weiter das sind große getragene kirchen
choräle die entnommen sind textlich
einmal den evangelien
zum anderen im saal wenn also das sieht
man ganz deutlich welche innige
verbindung zwischen diesen beiden
bereichen besteht also ist keine
offenbarungsreligionen in stadion aber
jetzt ein religiöses gefühl und aus
diesem religiösen gefühle heraus geht
auch der einzelne
wir müssen auch den einzelnen wieder
bedenken von numark geht dann gestärkt
und erhoben nach hause ich würde gerne
an dieser stelle einen eine frage
einbringen einer zuschauerin die uns
geschrieben hat anita steinmann sie
schreibt in der antiken an das theater
neben den inhaltlichen spektakel auch
eine pädagogische funktion ein
die zuschauer sollten geläutert und
moralisch belehrt nach hause gehen
ist eine solche erzieherische komponente
heute auch im fußball zu finden
diesmal gern noch zuerst kurzer
repliziert dass diese religiöse meines
erachtens wieder über der terminierung
des fußballspiels natürlich gibt es so
etwas wie rituale und natürlich gibt es
auch etwas wie kollektive identität
bietet um über sport
das trifft nicht nur den fußball obwohl
das auch schon ziemlich aufgebrochen
mir erscheint und das wollen in
massenbewegungen einen kollektiven ganz
ganz starke emotionen entwickelt werden
können
das hat auch die psychologie früher
schon man in geschäftlicher skate oder
sigmund freud erkannt dass heißt es
stimmt schon was wichtigen mehr
interessierte ist nachdem das ganze ein
spiel ist und dass auch gespielte
emotionen sind wie ernst nehmen fans
tatsächlich diese identifikation diese
integrationsangebote bisher bestimmt das
wirklich ihr leben oder wie sehr kann
man hier das ist meine erfahrung
bisher kann man hier sozusagen auch
seine mannschaft tatsächlich wechseln
ich bin ich bin meine erste
fußball-weltmeisterschaft nicht bewusst
erlebt aber 1966 dort österreich nicht
teilgenommen
sehr wohl deutschland was wir vielleicht
nahe stehen hätte können aber meine
mannschaft war portugal ich war hier
damals hat die wir eben dass zwei wochen
gedauert so einfach ein portugiese das
heißt also nehmen wir das vielleicht
auch nicht allzu ernst was hier an
identifikation angeboten läufen zu haben
scharinger
erzieher in dieser frage es wird
natürlich immer wieder behauptet ja das
natürlich weil es um ein spiel sich
handelt dass bestimmte regeln hat die
eingehalten werden müssen weil auch
bestimmte formen von akzeptanz des
gegners vorhanden sein muss weil und
bestimmte formen von respekt auch da ist
weil es auch darum geht emotionen zu
zügeln
neben der spieler und übrigens auch das
publikum ja auch die zuschauer nicht ein
emotionen freien lauf lassen also wenn
sie über die stränge schlagen wenn
spieler und beherrscht wird wenn er
gegen die regeln verstößt dann wird das
sanktioniert ganz klar bis hin zum
ausschluss das kann man ohne steinkogler
das interessante ist beim spiel kann ich
jemanden der faul macht ausschließen er
in einer schulklasse darf ich das schon
lange nicht mehr tun
ja das ist also das wäre paradox im
griechischen theater der fahrweise eine
reinigung der seele dagegen gewandt dass
cook wird ja behauptet da stimmt das
nicht und das griechische theater hatte
eine blüte von 75 jahren insgesamt und
wir tun ja mal so zu sagen dass tausende
von jahren gewesen
das ist ja nicht der fall und ich denke
auch beim fußball muss man vorsichtig
sein
ich bin vollkommen recht verließ man im
schiedsrichter kann bösen spieler
ausschließen dass es auch bisher wie
beim kasperletheater sozusagen der
bösewicht wird ausgeführt kritik rote
karte wird niedergebrüllt verschwindet
unter der dusche auch schön das aber
nicht sehr pädagogisch glaube ich für
die zuschauer
ich glaube es gibt viel zu viel
schlechte beispiele auf fußballplätzen
von spielern die sich gehen lassen die
rüpeleien machen hinter dem hinter dem
rücken der zuschauer in den rücken des
schiedsrichters so dass er nicht gesehen
wird
meine frau ist die man erst in slow
motion erkennen kann in der zeitlupe
also das hat keinen tollen pädagogischen
wert das behaupten immer die
feuerwehrrente aber wird es zeit ist das
eine schutzbehauptung müssen auch mal
realistisch dieses spiel ist
faszinierend behaupte ich nach wie vor
eben weil es eben immer noch roh ist
trotz allem und die spieler sind eben
immer noch dreckig wenn sie hinterher
zur siegerehrung kommen sie spielen
immer noch in kurzen hosen und sie
müssen immer noch mit ihren füßen ihre
füßen hinhalten und ihre kinder tun
diese diese dimension die widerspricht
ja eigentlich so ein bisschen diesen
pseudo religiösen wir haben uns über
dieses pseudo religiösen gesprochen in
zusammenhang mit den fans aber lassen
sie uns noch in zusammenhang mit den
spielern daran
wir sprechen da kommt dann natürlich
sofort der spieler maradona in dem
singen diese berühmte szene die er aus
der hand gottes in den weltfußball
eingegangen ist die welt fußball
geschichte ist erstens ich glaube ich
schauen oder finden sie ist lustig sie
können sich nachher dazu äußern als man
schauen wir uns diese szene kurz an 19
86 das entscheidende tor bei der wm
maradona gegen england darüber habe es
zu dieser szene aus maradona mit der
hand eigentlich dieses entscheidende tor
erzielt hat und man sah nach ja sehr
eindeutig es war immens und es ging dann
aber eben die idee endlich geschichte
ein das war die hand gottes und es gibt
auch schweine für maradona also das ist
ja ich habe hier ein bild maradona
schreien mit seinen haaren capella
mirakulöse für maradona ein schöner
schein also diese pseudo religiöse
deutung des fußballers dies auch
interessant herr ließ man also wenn wenn
fußballer ein tor erzielt und die hand
war im spiel werden wir eine 99 prozent
der fußballer hinter sagen nein das war
ganz in ordnung also ich hab es nicht
gespielt habe ich nicht gesehen als das
einfach leuten ja und dass deswegen ist
das legendär geworden weil maradona das
zugegeben hat aber auch ehrlich zugeben
konnte dass er sich regelwidrig
verhalten hat und sei es halten sonst
als wunderschöne mit der hand gottes im
spiel gefunden hat ist für mich jetzt
nicht wirklich ausdruck einer also sagen
religiösen dimension des fußballs oder
des stürmers oder des stars wobei
natürlich sagen kann ich mein erstes
festgestellt hat walter benjamin mal
sagen kann dass der moderne star kult
schlechthin eine art von säkularisierte
religiosität sieht man da das ist das
ist in der popkultur ein unterschied
also ich finde das ist natürlich richtig
also dass der moderne star kult aber
vielleicht zurück zu ihrer frage die
sich schon von einigen minuten gestellt
haben nach dem nationalismus oder dem
nationalen element also im unterschied
zu den den sonstigen stars die wir so
kennen die sind groß
den internationalen filmstars zum
beispiel sind natürlich fußball ist er
eindeutig national zugeordnet also
natürlich gibt es diese mannschaft
spiele da spielen sie in einer
mannschaft die unter anderem nicht ihre
ist aber wenn wir jetzt von der em oder
der wm oder also diesen internationalen
wettbewerben ausgehen da gibt es
natürlich so ziehen auch ein element wo
diese verehrung eine starke soziale
nationalistische schlagseite hat und da
glaube ich ist da geht es dann da geht
so eine pseudo religiösen ein pseudo
nationalistisches über möglicherweise
oder auf jeden fall wird da und das ist
ja sozusagen das ist der claim den man
in deutschland jetzt seit 2006 immer hat
da wird eine art von entschärft und
nationalismus gepflegt also der
sozusagen ehemals gefährliche und
betrügerische und aggressive m
nationalismus weder selbst durch einen
spielerischen ja es ist ja nur ein
erlauben lassen sie uns gleich auf
diesen aktionismus zu sprechen kommen
würde ganz gerne noch ein g power denn
das wort geben zu maradona ja ich habe
mich mit der sache nun ziemlich
ausführlich beschäftigt und ich würde
jetzt nicht sagen dass das sind einfach
nur pseudo religiös oder so etwas
maradona kommt aus einem bereich
argentiniens in dem er verehrt wird er
hat eine kirche er gilt als heiliger ist
in neapel verehrt worden daher auch der
schrein erst 1987 mannschaftskapitän von
ssc neapel geworden und die mannschaft
war vorher sehr schlecht und sieht
plötzlich italienischer meister geworden
neapel ist ohnehin eine gegend eine
stadt in der man sehr gerne glaubt alles
mögliche glaubt es auch eine heidnische
stadt die die christlichen glauben und
den heidnischen glauben miteinander
verbunden hat zum beispiel die feste
überzeugung dass maradona in die abel
eine wiederkehr des stadtheiligen san
gennaro sei der ist im jahre 500
enthauptet worden und nun san gennaro
maradona madonna und so war das sind
alles auch konzentrationen die da sind
die in neapel gespielt worden sind es
wird auch jedes jahr bei großen
veranstaltungen eine prozession
veranstaltet wo maradona ein maradona
darsteller auftritt der wird als bischof
verkleidet hat die bischofsmütze auf ein
bischofs mantel
er wird in einem alten vw durch die
stadt kutschiert das ist schon ein star
ein kult der sich unterscheidet vom
üblichen aber gleichzeitig eben auch
ironisch und deswegen ist das ganz
wichtig was er gestern gesagt hat dass
wir hinten müssen ob das auch alles so
ganz ernst
es gibt sicher leute die aus dem fenster
springen wenn ihre mannschaft verlieren
aber ohnehin gefährdete menschen überaus
allerdings ist seit je als göttinnen
aber hier sieht man sie ja wir endlich
mal keine eigenen heiligen schreine da
muss man es hat auch ein schneider kita
ist mama wir denken dass man das was man
sonst als die ampel und das mit wenig so
die verehrung von großem fußball ist ja
immens die es ihm aber sich erst auch es
so sind wir uns auch zu denken geben ja
so muss man den ball fallen ja auf ihren
eigenen kultur ein das ist ja das
interessante also die ganz berühmten
fußballern begegnen dann sieht man dass
die selber sich vergessen ganz
gefährlich
aber dann möchte ich doch noch mal einen
haken diese immense verehrung die hat
schon etwas auch mit der nation zu tun
also weil es nicht nur leute sind die
göttliche spielen sondern leute die uns
den triumph gebracht haben also ein ganz
zu trennen ist das nicht davon also
diese ganz gut so ich glaube da gibt es
dieses element weil das eben nicht nur
menschen sind wo man mit erstaunen der
bewunderung ihr unglaubliches können auf
dem spielfeld und so weiter sieht
sondern die leute die uns kollektiv als
nation das gefühl haben gegeben haben
etwas gewonnen zu haben und da kommen
wir ja nicht zurück mental ist die firma
anfang gebracht haben mit der metapher
des krieges auf dem auf dem spiel also
die die sieger die denn die die krieger
die den sieg nach hause tragen und da
möchte ich noch ein zweites tor keines
zuschauer so eine frage eines zuschauers
noch einbringen jahren 4 sa der fragt
was ist von der these zu halten was
sport im allgemeinen und fußball im
besonderen den menschen gerade deshalb
so stark bewegt weil dieser sich als
optimierung von aggressionen oder gar
verschärft gesprochen aus sublimieren
des triebes zum krieg erweist kann sich
aber gesagt ja ich kann mit dem trieb
zum krieg nicht so richtig viel anfangen
also ich weiß nicht ob menschen
unbedingt kriegerisch sein müssen ich
denke das hängt sehr stark davon ab wie
sie sozialisiert worden sind aber es ist
natürlich auf dem feld etwas da was man
auch fordert von fußballern dass sie
aggressiv spielen aber es ist richtig
dass das so plädiert werden musste man
kann den aggression nicht direkt
raushalten
aber ich warne davor fußballvereine
nachfolge des krieges oder ihn überhaupt
in die nähe eines krieges zu bringen
weil dafür ist er viel zu komplex viel
zu anders er wird ja auch zum beispiel
mit einem ball gespielt das wird ja mal
vernachlässigt da sind ja nicht da tritt
ja nicht der spieler an und ballert mit
einer kanone sondern muss den ball
beherrschen und er muss den ball so
beherrschen dass er ihn ins tor bekommt
das gericht aber nicht immer nur durch
ballern zustande sondern manchmal durch
streicheln durch schlenzen durchpassen
dadurch aus den ball ganz geschickt am
torwart vorbei rollen lässt und so weiß
er ganz viel auch mit erotischer
konnotation zu tun den ball irgendwie
über die linie bringen und so weiter ja
das wird immer vergessen dabei wie sehen
sie das
also wird jetzt diese parallelisierung
von krieg und sport auch nicht
übertreiben
historisch gesehen gibt es natürlich
gemeinsame wurzeln ist ganz ganz andere
sportarten sich eben aus
kampfsituationen entwickelt haben also
das mittelalter turnier zum beispiel
vorbild für ganze reihe von
kampfsportarten hat natürlich auch mit
der ursprünglichsten form des kampfes zu
tun im boxen ist also überdeutlich noch
immer vorhanden und es geht im fußball
schon um die auseinandersetzung den
wettkampf weil wir sagen jetzt nicht
wettbewerb sondern wettkampf zwischen
mannschaften aber natürlich ein super
mieter vor wild kultivierter form also
bei aller primitivität alles was sie
gesagt haben hat natürlich mit
kultivierung und ästhetisierung zu tun
der in ganz ganz starke unterstreichen
genau also auch ethisch moralische und
könnte man sagen
und zur frage der zuschauerinnen das ist
eine alte theorie der wesentlich auf
konrad lorenz uhr zurück geht das den
menschen angeboren aggressionstrieb hat
und dass fußball eine möglichkeit ist
diesen trieb in zivilisierten formen
also sozusagen auszuleben oder oder oder
zu kanalisieren
ich würde auch sagen wir sind nicht alle
ständig so aggressiv aber
interessanterweise wenn es wirklich so
einen spannenden wettkampf geht aber zu
sehen gibt dann freut es dass unter
umständen natürlich schon und es
erfreuen uns ja natürlich ganze reihe
von aspekten die wirklich mit dieser das
könnte man es wirklich theatralisch
formulieren dialekte und dynamik von
sieg und niederlage zu tun haben was
heißt dass eine niederlage einstecken zu
müssen was heißt das fast gewonnen zu
haben vielleicht das ist doch sowas eine
katharsis oder gehört theater doch sowas
die erzieherische band oder einen
mitleiden diese sachen durchschreiten
wenn man mal schaut man wird ja nicht
unbedingt besser dadurch also die
niederlage lautet ja man lernt
vielleicht etwas aus niederlagen aber
das ist alles zu optimistisch und es
gibt auch so zu sagen es gibt auch
formen des spiels die die auch ihre
these von der ästhetik das streichen
dass zum beispiel die die schönen
spielen selten gewinnen ja die gerade
kommt ein problem viel energie ist oder
sich zurückzuziehen phänomen des
nationalismus eingebracht haben ich
würde da gerne vielleicht eine steile
these einbringen von stefan reich
redakteur des magazins 11 freunde der
hat kürzlich gesagt dass er glaubt dass
dieser party patriotisch musste eben
2006 im deutschen sommermärchen so stark
wurde dass der eigentlich möglicherweise
die wiege sei von kita und afd
aus dem grunde genommen aus diesem
spielerischen nationalismus heraus
diesen patriotismus heraus etwas
negatives wachsen konnten ein sprecher
der kopf sind das ja eine furchtbare
these die hand darauf gebracht hat ich
liebe die er freunde und auch ihre
redakteure finde ich ausgezeichnet aber
das verstehe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
also der ich finde auch das wort party
patriotismus scheußlich es war einfach
so es war sommer plötzlich es war 2006
eine chance dieses wetter die wm fängt
an und im selben moment geht es
sozusagen die sonne auf und die deutsche
mannschaft gewinnt das beben traf
schließlich ja natürlich man glaubt ja
sowas
es war einfach eine klasse stimmung im
land und man hat die gegner geehrt auch
die ge verloren haben man hat mit ihnen
zusammen gefeiert das stimmt natürlich
deutschland hat sich präsentiert als ein
land das zwar jetzt an die eigene
mannschaft glaubt die hat man nicht
vorher für ganz besonders schlecht
gehalten und nun spielt sie plötzlich
einen zauberhaften fußball jedenfalls
eine ganze zeit lang das war sozusagen
eine befreiung endlich mal wieder eine
mannschaft die gut spielt die was kann
sie sogar gewinnt usw
die sich gut benimmt und man hat mit den
nachbarn rüber gegrüßt meine nachbarn
sind argentinier deutschland gegen
argentinien gewonnen
dann haben die ihre fahne reingeholt gut
ich habe zwar keine gehabt aber oder es
fink von anfang an das wurden fahnen
gezeigt ich dachte sie ein
uneingeschränkt positives phänomen
und eingeschränkt ist ja nie weiß was
mit nationalismus zu tun hat aber in
deutschland konnte man bis dahin
jedenfalls meine generation nicht das
deutschland lied singen jedenfalls nicht
öffentlich privat sowieso nie man konnte
keine deutsche fahne irgendwo am auto
haben und man konnte auch zu hause keine
deutschen insignien haben und nun hat
eine mannschaft gewonnen und dann hängen
die leute bescheiden erst mal so eine
deutsche fahne an ihr auto und manche
hamster in ihrem vase gepflanzt und
ähnliches und haben dann auch mal
geguckt plötzlich konnte man das den
text des deutschlandliedes das war neu
ja also angefangen
ich verstehe diese begeisterung diesem
spezifischen kontext wenn wir schweizer
haben ja kein problem mit einer fahne im
garten aber das ist für deutschland als
unschön gewesen
und in dem sinne hat das auch was ganz
harmlos ist also ob er auch die
emotionen der schöne waren aber
natürlich muss man letztlich von der
logik der sache her
es gab ja jetzt in diesem herrlichen
vorschlag des satiremagazins der
postille und das ist jetzt von der ab
jetzt nur noch eine europäische
mannschaft gibt nicht mehr einzelne
europäische union
und da ist ja der politik merkels
vorschlag darauf reingefallen und hat
das eine furchtbare idee gefunden weil
er unbedingt eine deutsche mannschaft
brauchen also natürlich ist es da sieht
man schon also dass zumindest dann wenn
er hat schon vorsprung vor formen oder
eben vielleicht man denkt es eine
harmlose form von nationalismus aber
letztlich finde ich hat es dann
natürlich kann es auch im umschlag in
gewalt also dieses dieses robuste dieses
gegröle also ich meine diese emotionen
die man kann sagen da werden emotionen
ausgelebt die werden dann zu hause nicht
mehr
also da wird man dann kann man die
sozusagen loswerden im stadium und man
kann auch sagen da werden die kultiviert
und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob die
these stimmt aber ich finde sie erst mal
bedenken verließ man ein kurzes motto
noch zum thema nationalismus
also ich denke solange man auf aus
welchen gründen auch immer glaubt
nationalmannschaften gegeneinander
antreten lassen zu müssen
und solange identifikation mit einer
mannschaft wesentliches moment ist es
überhaupt anzusehen ja wird sozusagen
natürlich dann diese formen von
nationalgefühl in welcher spielerischen
partymäßig geläuterten leichten vor
notwendigerweise geben müssen ich kann
nicht auf der einen seite schreiben
viele jahre nicht mehr ich finde wenn
man vom nationalismus nicht mehr haben
als das alle zwei jahre menschen sich
mit seiner fußballmannschaft für 14 tage
identifizieren dann haben wir dieses
problem gelöst sein
und egal auch nicht dass über also sagen
solche sportlichen integrationsangebote
tatsächlich ein politischer
nationalismus entstehen kann alle
gestärkt werden kann zumal gerade im
fußball würde vorher schon sagen das
stimmt nämlich nicht ganz
der nationale fußball ist mittlerweile
längst die ausnahmesituation und nicht
die regel
die gothaer da wirklich da wirklich
große fußballer sind die internationalen
clubs und dort spielt keiner also bei
den großen klubs egal ob in england ob
in frankreich spiels was niemand wer aus
diesem land der dass ein internationaler
zusammengekaufte superkicker wo es
völlig egal ist woher der kommt wird er
angehört werden eingeladen kurzzeitig
benutzer gezwungen
im fußball sind am ende dieses
stammtisches wir beschließen den
stammtisch er es mit unserer tipprunde
jetzt nicht mehr tätig sondern einer
philosophischen tipps oder wir bringen
alle immer etwas mit was philosophisch
uns gerade sozusagen auf dem tisch liegt
oder irgendwo in istrien kocht frau mag
was ist ihnen wichtig heute ich habe von
bettina standard das buch böses denken
mitgebracht ein philosophisches buch
aber ein ganz will das buch ein essay
der auch überhaupt nicht akademischen
regeln folgt und sich mit der frage nach
dem bösen auseinandersetzung spezielle
stimmt bösen denken denn es gibt in der
philosophie ja seit der aufklärung die
frauchen das denken uns in irgendeiner
weise besser macht moralisch besser
macht und uns auch weil wir selber
denken davor bewahrt dass wir dann böses
tun
das ist eine illusion die unter anderem
hannah arendt unterlaufen hat und
bettina stangneth nimmt das noch einen
schritt weiter und auch in die heutige
politik hinein und auch da hinein wo man
eben sagt es ist möglicherweise so dass
es leute gibt die sehr gut denken und
sehr gut selber denken und trotzdem
böses tun wollen und das finde ich eine
sehr anregende lektüre ok-power das ist
ein film von jako von domain im
belgischen regisseur das brandneue
testament
dass der inhalt ist gott lebt die
schlechte botschaft ist er ist ein ganz
böser gott
er sitzt unrasiert morgenmantel in einem
belgischen appartement im zwölften stock
und sind nur darüber nach wir die
menschen was böses tun kann
und eines tages erwischte kleine tochter
er das passwort von dem vater für seinen
bösen computer schleicht sich entweder
als er schläft und teilt allen menschen
mit zu welchem zeitpunkt sie sterben
werden plötzlich erscheint über jeden
bild von jedem menschen das sterbedatum
und dann wird die welt ganz anders und
das ist philosophisch hochinteressant so
weiterdenken dankeschön für die täter
ließ man ja es würde mich wundern wenn
in den kommentaren der nächsten wochen
nicht ständig von kreativen spielern
kreative zügen kreativen trainern und
kreativen journalisten die rede sein
würde
um dem einen riegel vorzuschieben aber
vorzuschieben ein buch mitgebracht des
kunsthistorikers und kunstkritikers
wolfgang ullrich der kreative mensch er
verfolgt diese idee warum glauben wir
dass eine kreativ sein müssen warum
halten wir uns auch selbst erklärt warum
es kreativität und kompetenz sie war
schon im kindergarten versuchen
beizubringen
und es zeigt sich dass diese idee eine
geschichte hat eine höchst ambivalente
geschichte und aus dieser kreativitäts
imperativ von dem rührig spricht uns
ziemlich belastet nicht nur die kicker
ich habe ein buch aber erst an zweiter
stelle und erster stelle möchte ich
gerne die manifesta tippen die große
kunst biennale die dieses jahr in zürich
stattfindet sie öffnet sozusagen
gleichzeitig jetzt wie die em ihre tore
dauer bis zum 18 september hat ganz
verschiedene ausstellungen theater
künstlerische expeditionen zu bieten
ganz ein ganz breites programm auch mit
einem rahmenprogramm alles unter einem
philosophischen motto nämlich ort titel
do for money und ich glaube sozusagen
die philosophische fußnote oder den
unterbau bietet dieses buch hier was man
viel geld nicht kaufen kann von michael
sandel das buch ist schon ein paar jahre
alt aber unbedingt eine lektüre wert
gerade jetzt die keine lektüre wert wenn
man sich an die manifesta begibt war ja
ganz viele
spiel drin sind war es eigentlich mit
den menschen passiert wenn alles
käuflich wird beispielsweise die
vorstellung dass viele reiche leute ihre
autos einfach irgendwo parken wo es
verboten ist und die boost sozusagen als
gebühr uminterpretieren eine gebühr die
man sich einfach ein berechnen kann
im budget also ein buch das sich lohnt
wenn man zwar nicht es da geht ja wir
sind am ende unseres stammtisch ich
danke ihnen sehr für das mitdiskutieren
ich möchte gerne schließen mit einem
zitat des großen fußballs rot-rot
kingson im hinblick auf die em
ich wage keine prognose es könnte so
oder so vielen dank fürs mit diskutieren
dankeschön
zeitgleich mit der em trifft wie gesagt
eben auch die kunst auf mit der
manifesta die in zürich zu gast ist die
sternstunde kunst zeigt zur eröffnung
der biennale heute gleich zwei filme
jetzt gleicht das porträt der us
amerikanischen künstlerin kiki smith die
mit bronze wachs und gibt ihr ganz
eigenes universum erfindet um 23.10
zeigen wir ihnen den film über den
schweizer künstler thomas hirschhorn der
den italienischen philosophen gramsci
mit viel inbrunst ein denkmal setzt wir
sehen uns wieder nächste woche dann ist
der wortgewaltige tausendsassa islams
scheck zu gast mit ihnen diskutieren
über neue und alte ideologien und über
sein plädoyer für einen neuen
eurozentrismus sich überhaupt zu wort
kommen
ich bin gespannt ich hoffe sie auch und
ich wünsche ihnen einen guten sonntag
[Musik]